when you heard the mini Budget on the  23rd of September did you think that's a  good idea or did you think what on Earth  are they playing at  no I let's be completely honest with UK  when the mini budget was presented to us  in the cabinet meeting uh immediately  for the before the Chancellor's  statement each and every one of those  measures was consistent with the  approach to growth that the government  was seeking and we all in gov in cabinet  accept Collective responsibility for the  fact that that mini budget was given and  it is important for all of us to be very  honest about that it's not just the  Prime Minister who made that mistake  although she has owned it and apologized  for it  are you sorry yes a hundred percent